jean d'ormesson dieu sa vie son oeuvre
qui était un très beau titre je me suis
dit est ce que vous avez trouvé le titre
puis vous ai dit finalement ce qui est
si beau faut que j'écrive absolument un
livre sur dieu pour le justifier
ou est ce vous avez d'abord écrit le
livre puis ensuite vous avez trouvé le
tic vous savez je crois que montherlant
disait qu'il ne fallait jamais commencer
un livre sans avoir d'abord le titre et
il ya eu un titre que quelqu'un utilisé
à plusieurs reprises le diable sa vie
son oeuvre a dans sa vie son oeuvre
jamais dû on n'était pas monté jusqu'à
dieu sa vie son oeuvre
alors le titre mais sûrement lui très
vite pas le le thème du livre c'est
extrêmement simple c'est dieu personne
n'oblige dieu a créé lyon il le crée par
un libre choix bas et le livre et
l'hésitation de dieu avant de créer le
livre se termine à la création du monde
après nous tombons dans la navy tonnes
il veut un peu vite d'abord bon vous
êtes à quai à dieu est-ce que vous avez
été vous dit où je crois que vous avez
été assez angoissé qu'en inde écrit un
livre sur dur
écoutez franchement oui parce que vous
avez bien vu comme madame yourcenar a
hésité quand vous lui avez dit est ce
que dieu est un sujet de roman non dieu
n'est pas un sujet de roman et en plus
ce ne suis même pas sûr qu'on ait le
droit de parler de dieu
vous savez que dans toute la la la la
mystique juive
on ne parle pas de dieu on parle à dieu
on ne parle pas de dieu et c'est presque
ma justification pour avoir fait un
roman parce qu'on ne peut pas parler de
dieu
on ne peut rien dire de dieu on peut
peut-être faire de la fiction sur dieu
c'est tout ce qu'on peut faire parce que
dieu est entièrement hors de notre
atteinte et je dirais que faire un roman
sur dieu est presque une forme de
respect parce qu'on ne peut rien n'en
dira
mais vous vous laissez entendre parce
qu'un certain manque au fond dieu aurait
pu vous mettre sur terre pour écrire ce
livre et qui vous a inspiré probablement
mais pas d'une certaine façon il vous a
mis son père bien c'est comme puisqu'il
a tout prévu et que tout est vu par lui
je prends par exemple chateaubriand
comme exemple comme échantillon de ce
que voit dieu mais il nous a aussi prévu
pour nous réunir ici tous les trois ce
soir qu'il a vu sa main mais
naturellement il a vu tout ce que c'est
c'est le suspect est plus élémentaires
sur dieu sait que pour dieu le monde
entier passé présent futur est un
éternel présent et au moment de créer le
monde il voit le monde comme un éternel
présent
moi pas c'est pour ça que j'ai obligé de
choisir à l'intérieur du bus mais vous
écrivez vous-même il y as je lui avoue
quelque chose d'assez comique avoir dû
passer par mois pour chanter son saint
nom
oui c'est vrai parce que maintenant nous
pas peut être tenté de me présenter soit
comme un poète soi que la philosophe
soit comme un mystique et évidemment je
crois que je suis obligée de récuser c3
c3 vocable flatteur bon alors voici donc
chroniqueur de dieu c'est d'ailleurs
l'expression vous employez dans ce roman
il y a deux histoires qui sont
parallèles mais qui sont imbriquées
l'une dans l'autre
c'est donc l'histoire de dieu et de son
dialogue qui va d'ailleurs mal se
terminer avec sa première créature
lucifer et puis c'est l'histoire de
personnages de petites fourmis l'échelle
de dieu qui vivent dans la première
moitié du 19e siècle et dont les cds
principal fourmis s'appelle
chateaubriand madame récamier les
hortense à l'arrêt puis sa mère et sa
grand mère et puis aussi quelqu'un
d'assez intéressant qui s'appelle le
[ __ ] de pontarlier
bon alors d'abord alors pourquoi qu'est
ce qui rassemble à la fois cette
histoire donc au plus haut niveau
et puis cette histoire de ce petit
personnage même s'il s'appelle
châteaubriant alors le seul point que je
voulais défendre fortement c'est l'idée
que ce livre est très rigoureux il est
très rigoureux parce que on ne peut pas
parler du créateur autrement qu'en
passant par les créatures
alors si vous voulez faire le roman de
dieu vous êtes obligés de faire le roman
de la création parce que vous n'avez pas
d'autres moyens
et dieu lui même regarde l'ensemble du
monde
alors comme dieu a déjà fait le monde
moi je viens en 2d ce pas et je ne peux
pas refaire tout le monde à l'intérieur
de mes cinq ou six cents pages donc je
suis obligé de prendre des échantillons
et châteaubriant et tous les autres
personnages dont vous parlez sont très
précisément des échantillons ce qui me
frappe toujours dans les romans c'est
qu'on vous donne quelques réussi qui
soit c'est qu'on vous donne une histoire
merveilleuse mais elle est tout à fait
arbitraire n'est ce pas j'ai voulu faire
sentir et c'est le seul petit décalage
métaphysique que je demande faire sentir
que tout est arbitraire et que mon dieu
peut nous regarder nous en ce moment
mais il regarde en même temps la
bataille de marignan qu'à 115 et
l'invention du feu et alors il faut
choisir quelques échantillons pour
montrer à type 2 en guise de modèle
ce que sera le monde exactement comme si
vous fait faire un costume vous revenez
avec un échantillon est là est ce que
vous voulez montrer surtout la liberté
des créatures par rapport à dieu ou bien
au contraire leur exprime suggestions
par rapport aux créateurs les deux n'est
ce pas si dieu n'avait pas créé
c'est que c'est tout à fait ça on en
écrit souvent non pas je le prends pas
comme un reproche que c'était tout à
fait ça bien sûr c'est tintin dans la
métaphysique nous passer c'est c'est du
niveau du catéchisme
si dieu n'avait pas créé la liberté tout
serait respect en dieu vous comprenez ça
s'il n'y avait pas la liberté humaine
qui permet de s'écarter de dieu qui
permet de choisir contre
mais tout serait resté dans un dieu est
la seule façon pour dieu de créer
quelque chose qui ne soit pas compris en
lui
c'était de donner la liberté de choisir
contre lui alors sautant quelques
milliards d'années arrivons à la wii
parce qu'on met pas oui et arrivant
pourquoi dieu crie-t-il lucifer parce
que il faut qu'il crée quelque chose
n'est-ce pas il faut qu'il crée quelque
chose qui soit extérieur à lui eu le
pardon de dire des choses qui sont très
très élémentaire mais quand on est en
classe de philosophie on apprend que
pour rigole le tout c'est le rien et
quand on arrive en classe de philosophie
on est toujours un peu étonné de savoir
que le rien ils tous c'est la même chose
mais c'est extrêmement clair quand il
n'y a rien le rien c'est le tout c'est
tout à fait clair et il faut donc
différencier les choses et c'est là que
dieu créé lucifer qui est un être
d'amour mais qui a sa liberté est
naturellement dieu sait déjà que cette
liberté se retournera contre lui et ce
sera le début d'une malle le début de la
liberté le début de la forêt le début
d'histoire